Jag saknade ändå åren innan covid.
Det var inte så jättemycket som stora grejer som hände, men nu efter det så var det covid, brand, krig, lågkonjunktur, översvämning.
Men är det så, nu gick vi in, du ska få berätta lite om det själv, men jag bara hoppar in här lite.
Nu kanske jag får skit för detta, men jag säger...
Jag håller med.
Men, vad brinner ni mest för?
Då välkomnar vi Sara Sidenblad till podden som driver varumärket Gigamoja.
Och jag kan ju säga, det var inte meningen men i morse så när jag tog på en av mina ungar sin mössa, då var det en Gigamoja-mössa och det var en sån Gigamoja-mössa som när jag läste historien här om Gigamoja, så såg jag att den möstdesignen fanns redan 2007.
Det är en helfärgad med vita ränder på.
Så välkommen till podden Sara.
Och har ni samma modeller som ni hade 2007?
Ja men tack så jättemycket, ja det har vi.
Det var roligt, ja.
Vi är en klassiker i sortimentet.
Så att, och där finns ju, jag vet inte hur många färger vi gjort den där mössan i men ja, flera hundra troligtvis.
Jag tror till och med vi har den som är på bilden.
Det var en blå mössa och så har den loggaren här framme.
Jag tror det är exakt den.
Ja vad kul, roligt.
Ja den har han haft i något år och jag tror hans storebror hade den innan så att den har ju inte varit tag.
Ja det är bra.
Det är precis det vi vill, att det ska hänga kvar.
Är inte det ett problem att saker återanvänds?
Jag förstår att det är rent emotionellt, det är sådär fint men man vill göra kunder.
Ja men precis, men förr tänkte vi så.
Vi har ju faktiskt jobbat väldigt mycket med att våra kunder ska förstå att våra produkter håller länge och framförallt har ett andrahandsvärde.
Så vi har ju precis lanserat en pre-loved försäljning också för att vi ska få kunderna att förstå att gör jag en investering i en skaljacka som kostar nära 1000 lappen så är det ingenting som behöver gå till återvinning efter två år utan det finns fortfarande ett värde i produkten att kunna sälja vidare.
Det är lite tvetydligt men vi vill ju också vara ett varumärke med god kvalitet så det är det vi strävar efter, att det är många barn som ska kunna ha ett plagg.
Ja, jag känner ju till er uppenbarligen, men för folk som kanske inte har barn i den åldern, kan du inte bara beskriva lite kort vad det är ni säljer och vad ni sysslar med?
Ja, vi säljer kvalitativa barnkläder.
Vi brukar säga att vi vill nå från topp till tå.
Vi gör allt ifrån en napphållare till en superavancerad vinteroverål.
Men kvalitet och funktion är det som är fokus när vi skapar produkter helt enkelt.
Viktigt för oss är att hänga med i tiden.
Att nå den moderna mamman, och också den mamman som har ett intresse för hållbarhet och vill välja bra produkter till sina barn.
Som sagt, sortimentet är allt från napphållare till solglasögon till UV-kläder till vanliga kläder.
Men där vi också har väldigt mycket fokus på materialet.
Och att det liksom är ett hållbart val.
Jag har några frågor på det.
Nummer ett, du sa att jag följde med lite i tiden och sådär, men den här mössan som jag hade, den har ju varit med i snart 20 år.
Men den är som jeans då eller?
Den funkar alltid liksom.
Ja, men det är ju också någonting som jag tror har varit vår framgång, att vi har hittat en balans kring det där.
Och att vi har hittat ett klassiskt uttryck, som gör att produkterna håller länge.
Och man kan känna sig ganska trygg med sitt köp från oss.
Sen har vi absolut, det är inte lika känsligt som det med vuxenmode.
Och vi kan ju se, överdrivet av bolaget i 17 år, att vuxenmodet är mycket snabbare.
Barnmodet inspireras av vuxenmodet, men det kommer hjärnet ett par år efter.
När det kommer till färger och så där.
Så det är också något vi av erfarenheterna har gett oss.
Men vi försöker alltid, när vi gör våra kollektioner, tänka lite på det.
Att vi liksom ska inte släppa det klassiska, men vi måste också ha det som är lite mer emotiskt och tilltalar den målgruppen.
Ja, som ytterst ående tänker någonstans att barnkläder tas framut utifrån funktion.
Nu kommer ett nytt material som är mer regnansdötande.
Eller nu kommer något som man kan tvätta 8000 gånger.
Eller så där.
Men det finns ändå en viss modegrad som man följer.
Ja, men det gör det och tittar vi historiskt sett när vi började med Gegemoja, då var det ganska mycket skrika färger.
Man som förälder var inte rädd för att sätta färg på sina barn.
Nu är det ganska mer såbert mode.
Man ska liksom, inredningen och barnmodet ska matcha i hemmen.
Det kan vara ett storstadsfenomen men vi ser att det finns en efterfrågan att gå lite mer nedtonat än vad det gjorde bara för några år sedan.
Det finns trenden helt enkelt.
Jag tänker att ni tvärtom, jag gillar att sätta mössor på mina unga som är orange eller gröna, så att man ser dem i gruppen på något sätt.
Då kan man säga, där är de.
Men okej det är nedtonat som gäller nu.
Ja men det går lite åt det hållet faktiskt.
Men vi försöker verkligen också tilltala en bredare målgrupp.
Så att vi vill inte bara vara ett såväl beest varumärke, utan vi vill ju ha de här färgglada grejerna också såklart.
Hur funkar det med trender i, för ni har en hel del licenser, och jag vill komma in lite på det sen, men går det även modigt, för ni har Mamamoo, tror jag ni har väl Petson och Findus, som ni har gjort, och den här humlan som inte mina barn har kommit till än, men.
Humma Joy.
Och sen hade ni väl Pippi som vi rådde in här nu.
Går det mode i sådana grejer också, eller är de såpass tidlösa att det spelar liksom er roll?
Jag skulle säga att det finns en tidlöshet i det, men sen de som har de här licenserna, de har ju olika saker som händer kring karaktären.
Som till exempel i år så fyller Pippi Långström på 80 år, och då kliver ju de ju in och liksom jobbar väldigt mer aktivt med sina licensstagare.
Och det händer saker, liksom det är teatrar, det är nya böcker, det är nya filmer.
Så då blir det ju att alla tillsammans skapar någonting som liksom driver karaktären.
Och just nu de här åren så är ju liksom både mamma Mugo, Pettson och Pippi har ju haft stora högtider som ska firas.
Så det har varit ganska många aktörer i barn-
och babybranschen som har gjort olika produkter, olika evenemang för att lyfta karaktärerna.
Absolut, så är det ju.
Är det ni som har kontaktat dem här?
För det är ju ingen som har hört av sig till gymkompaniot och sagt att vi vill göra hantlar som är pippi, liksom starka hantlar.
Så är det ju inte.
Men vet, Karlineffa.
Men är det de här människorna som kontaktar dig eller är det ni som kontaktar dem?
Det har varit lite blandat.
Vi kände väl att vi ville börja titta på det.
För vi ville se hur man kan jobba med licenser.
Hade du frågat oss för tio år sen så hade det inte varit på tapeten.
Då hade det varit big no no.
Basse, hade det varit big no no?
Nej men för att då var inte de som jobbar med licenser så duktiga som de är nu.
Alltså att hitta varumärken som är kvalitativa för att sätta sina karaktärer på.
Men vi har ju liksom haft dialoger med de här licensföretagen i många år och sedan har det kommit öppningar där kanske det har varit så att det har funnit en licensstagare på kläder för en karaktär men de har slutat göra dem av en anledning.
Och då har liksom vi varit intressanta för att vi ser också att de som jobbar med licenser, de vill också jobba med kvalitet.
De vill ju sätta en kvalitetsstempel på sin karaktär.
Så det är en väldigt viktig aspekt att de varumärkena som de jobbar med ska vara bra eller om inte bäst i sitt segment.
Så det har varit lite olika tillbaka till din fråga om vi har kontaktat dem eller de har kontaktat med oss.
Men till exempel vi blev ju kontaktade av Astrid Lindgren som hade hittat oss för Pippi som första gången skulle göra ytterkläder och det var otroligt smickrande att en sån fin karaktär hör av sig till Lilla Gegemoja och vill göra ett sådant projekt.
Så det har för oss varit en väldigt bra kombination.
Med licenser har det också varit lite dörröppnare till nya marknader för att karaktärerna är starka på andra marknader än bara Sverige.
Så det har varit en jättespännande resa och vi har hittat en ganska bra balans mellan vilka karaktärer vi har och vårt egna sortiment om man säger så som inte har karaktärer på sig.
Så det har varit jättepopulärt.
Jag hade en diskussion med Linda på Vanguardi som var med här i podden också.
Då pratade jag lite om det här att fallhöjden blir lite större när man står för någonting.
Om Temu till exempel gör någonting dumt så är det ingen riktigt som bryr sig.
De gör redan, de har inte så stor fallhöjd i det där.
Men om ni är ett varumärke som har en viss kvalitetsdämpel, ni jobbar med vissa varumärken, är det krångligt ibland, för att ni måste ändå tänka på så otroligt mycket mer aspekter av hur mår den här fabriken, hur gör vi när vi skickar ut, hur är våra formspråk, det är så mycket som inkluderas i kvalitet på något sätt.
Hur ser ni in kring det?
Jag skulle nog säga att för vår del så har det liksom, det kommer naturligt.
Det har liksom varit med från början i vår resa.
Alltså kvalitet är ju ett av våra interna ledord, inte bara i produkten vi ska tillverka, utan även i hur vi bemöter våra kunder, vad vi har för dialog med leverantörer, hur vi är ut i branschen.
Att vi ska liksom, det ska inte slarvas någonstans.
Och ibland så kan jag och min syster, som jag driver Giga Maja tillsammans med, vi kan ju garva åt att vi är nere på detaljnivå, men vi vet ju också de gångerna då vi har fått betalt för att vi är inne på detaljnivå, att vi vill att vissa saker ska vara på vissa sätt.
Och varje kund är väldigt viktig.
Så att, ja, det är mycket att hålla koll på, men det faller naturligt på något sätt.
Jag fattar, det är ingenting som du känner press på utifrån, utan det är snarare, det är bara så ni är som.
Nej, jag tror snarare den första pressen kommer nog från mig och Anna själva, att det är så här vi vill att det ska vara, liksom.
Finns det en problematik där kring att det är krångligt att växa eller att det går långsamt, eller?
Ja, det gör det ju, alltså, vi drev ju Gegemoja ganska länge innan vi tog in nån partners i bolaget.
Och med liksom faset i hand så kanske vi skulle ha tagit in partners tidigare.
Men när vi tog in partners och fick mer kapital så löste vi ju en utav ett problem och det var ju att vi alltid sålt slut på grejer.
Vi har idag inte förlager som är nära liksom en två år gammalt.
Och det kan ju också, i den diskussionen vi hade innan den här inspelningen började, det kan ju också vara lite frustrerande när man gör en tillväxtresa att man vet att hade vi bara liksom lagrat upp lite mer, så hade vi kunnat sälja väldigt mycket mer.
Men hur gick den?
Ni har ju drivit bolaget som du säger rätt länge och jag tänker också ni är ju systrar och ni hade ju er mamma, det kan vi också spela så att ni hade er mamma som producent typ i början.
Eller hon gjorde kläderna, det var häftigt.
Men det skapar ju, speciellt då om man är lite detaljstyrd och liknande, när man ska ta in en investerare där först, då gissar jag att ni är rätt krånglig.
De flesta investerare kanske kommer och tänker att här jag gör er lite grann en tjänst.
För så blir det ju lite grann då.
Och då tänker jag att ni är såhär, ja här är vår kravlista på 32 krav, hur du ska vara som investerare och så.
Var det så eller hittade ni en bra match?
Vår första investerare, det var ganska roligt faktiskt, för jag satte styrelsen för ett annat bolag där den här personen var en av de största ägarna.
Och vi hamnade bredvid varandra och började prata lite.
Då kom vi in på Gagam och då sa han att jag är en av deras största kunder.
Vi hade då en butik på Grevturgatan, inne i stan i Stockholm, ganska många år.
Han sa att jag och mamma kände varandra, hon har oss på.
Jag sa att jag hade ingen koll på det, så jag pratade med mamma och hon sa att han gjorde dagskasserna.
Sen började vi förstå att den här personen gillar varumärket.
Han tyckte om det vi gjorde, det vi levererade, hur vi kommunicerade.
Det tog väl ett och ett halvt år innan han fick komma in.
Vi har ju kunnat se med det lilla kapitalsdiskottet vad vi har lyckats bygga, en omsättning från 15 till strax över 30.
Det har ju varit en superspännande resa såklart, men nu står vi i nästa skede, att nu ska vi upp mot 50 och 100.
I och med att vårt största problem är att lagret säljer slut.
Så vet vi att vi kan göra det ganska mycket med befintliga organisation, men vi behöver fylla på lagret, trycka marknadsföring och öka på de kanterna.
Det är kapital som håller er tillbaka på något sätt.
Ja, det är det.
Absolut.
Du sa att nu är ni i nästa steg, betyder det att ni är ut och kikar nu eller är det att ni redan har hittat någon?
Vi är ut och kikar.
Vi har pratat med flera olika typer av bolag.
Johanna börjar vi landa lite i vad vi har för behov.
Vi har pratat rena emissioner, vi har pratat exilistisk strategiska investerare som kanske har någon distribution som är intressant.
Vi har lite olika aktörer som vi tittar på just nu.
Det är en spännande fas, verkligen.
Men också i kombination av att titta på andra alternativ för att inte släppa för mycket av bolaget i det här skedet.
Det finns många vägar att gå.
Har ni någon tidshorisont för det här?
Eller är det mer bara att nu har ni börjat gå i de tankarna och då är man ut och kollar menyn?
Ja, men vi skulle behöva stänga någonting här innan sommaren.
För jag tror att känslan är att målen för 2025 är nog bara mer befintligt.
Men för att trycka på till 2026 så behövs det.
Vi jobbar ganska långa cykler.
Vi kan ju ha åtta månaders.
Från att vi bestämmer vad vi ska producera till nästa sommar, så är det åtta månader tills vi får hem grejerna.
Så jag vet redan nu vad vi ska sälja sommaren 2026.
Ja det är lite sjukt.
Vi har ju inga trender så vi kommer att sälja samma sak vi gör nu liksom.
Jag älskar att slippa justera någonting.
Men är det ni som sitter och designar?
Hur går hela cykeln till?
Kan du berätta lite?
Jo men absolut, självklart.
Anna är hos oss då, min medgrundare också.
Hon är ansvarig för design och produktion, tillsammans med en tjej som heter Hanna.
Så de gör egentligen förslag, men det som är viktigast för oss det är ju att jag då som ansvarar med för business to business-försäljningen och de som sitter på e-comm, att vi tillsammans pratar ihop oss.
Vad vill de här återköldarna ha?
Vad vill slutkunderna ha?
Vad efterfrågas?
Vi tittar extremt mycket på en historisk data.
Okej men hur snabbt sålde den här produkten slut?
Ja men det gick på tre månader, ja men då tar vi in den nästa vår igen.
Jag vill ju väldigt gärna tänka lite som du, att vi behöver inte uppfinna hjulet inom vissa segmenten på tiden.
Så där går vi ju mera åt att vissa saker är ett basortiment och där handlar det egentligen bara om att titta på okej, vad har vi köpt inför volymer tidigare?
Hur ser försäljningsprognosen ut hos våra största återförsäljare?
Hur ser det ut på e-handeln?
Och lägga den riskkalkylen helt enkelt.
Hur mycket kan vi köpa in?
Förhoppningsvis har vi så här mycket pengar i kassan då också.
Och har vi inte pengar i kassan då, hur löser vi det?
Men Anna, hon vill ta fram nya grejer och...
Ja, hon vill ta fram nya grejer, väldigt gärna.
Och det får hon göra.
Men det är ju ett högt tempo på design och produktion.
Det är ju det.
Vi menar bara de här samarbetena vi gör med karaktärerna.
Det är ett otroligt jobb att få ihop det.
Och så hitta rätt produkter.
I våran värld just nu så är det otroligt högt tryck på att man ska ha alla certifieringar på plats.
Vi som jobbar med hållbarhetsprodukter som har och har certifikat hit och dit, det är väldigt mycket administration kring den biten också.
Så det gäller verkligen att hunga rätt i mun och ha koll på grejerna vilket vi har.
Och ha ganska bra system för det.
Och det är också återigen till det här med kvalitet.
Vi ska veta vad våra kunder, våra kunder ska veta vad de köper och vi ska veta vad vi säljer.
Jag har alltid sagt det, jag vill inte sälja till barn.
Det måste vara den jobbigaste kunden som finns, föräldrar.
De har så mycket åsikter, de har så många frågor och det är så noga.
Och herregud, det låter bara jobbigt.
Känner du inte ibland att det var skönt det vore att sälja filtar till vuxna istället?
Jag vet inte.
Jag har aldrig sålt filtar till vuxna så jag ska nog inte testa på det heller.
Men absolut, det är en tuff målgrupp att jobba med.
Men där handlar det ju om att vi ska ju också bara göra ett ännu bättre jobb så att inte de där frågeteckorna ska finnas.
Det handlar ju om allt ifrån hur vi vill ha produktbeskrivningar till höra av oss med kvalitet till kunden och fråga varför du har retunerat den här på grund av storleksproblem.
Vi har en storleksguide, är det någonting annat som du hade velat ha haft med i när du tog ditt köpbeslut?
Det som ändå är skönt, jag kan tänka mig så här, jag brukar säga att jag är glad att jag inte jobbar med damoder som har typ 50% för returer.
Vi ligger på en returrad strax under fem och det är inte heller så mycket att bråka om egentligen.
Men absolut att vi kanske måste göra ett riktigt bra jobb innan köpbeslutet tas.
Och det jobbar vi med hela tiden, det är det vi ska jobba med.
Hur kontrollerar ni återförsäljare och sånt?
Hur ser ni till att det blir, dels kvalitativt och dels att det inte är...
Ni är ju ett ledigt bolag, jag menar inte att ni är små, men jag menar att återförsäljare inom kläder tenderar ju att vara betydligt större.
De säljer ju extremt mycket.
Hur gör ni för att inte bli uppätna av dem?
Men där gäller ju att jobba mycket med att hitta dels kvaliteten såklart, att vi vet vad vi hållbart får.
Och hitta nya material som de här större aktörerna kanske inte kan jobba med.
Vi jobbar till exempel mycket i bambu, som tycker vi är ett superhärligt material och har hittat en nisch bland det.
Vi försöker alltid ha lite smarta funktioner, ett designuttryck som både är det klassiska men också finns att tilltala de som vågar lite mera.
Jag vet också att ni säljer en del av er kollektion och så återförsäljar vi det, men inte hela, visst är det så?
Ja men precis, det där har varit en, när vi grundade bolaget så ville vi bygga ett varumärke för barn.
Vi hade ingen intission, vi hade en e-handel redan 2007, men det var inte e-handeln som då var det som peakade, utan då stod barnbutiker och återförsäljare på kö.
Du menar 2007, så vad hände?
Så att då, men sen så har ju liksom, i och med att vi är ett litet bolag och vi brukar säga att medan många andra är stora lastfartyg så är vi i vattenskotern som bara hoppar liksom i vågorna.
Och nu kan jag ha fel på årtalen då, men jag tror att det var kanske 2016-2017 tror jag det var, som vi bara bestämde oss att vi hade en ganska stökig återförsäljabranche då.
Som vi liksom, och vi ville skapa väldigt mycket produkter som återförsäljare inte ville köpa in.
De hade andra leverantörer på saker och ting.
Och då började vi jobba liksom med mer och mer produkter som bara fanns hos oss.
Det vill säga ytterkläder, skalkläder och liknande produkter.
Så då blev det liksom som en online only produkt.
Sen har med den här åren gått så har vi liksom hittat andra försäljningskanaler där vi liksom också erbjuder de produkterna.
Det kan vara alltifrån Zalando eller Stadium eller Oleums.
Men vi har liksom verkligen försökt produktdifferensiera sortimentet litegrann.
Du sa att ni var en vattenskoter här.
Jag tänker att ni har jobbat under så många år, du har väl 17 år, har man väl sagt.
Då blir man ju lite bekväm eller man lär sig sitt arbetssätt och sitt team och sin grej.
Nu har ni på ganska kort tid gått från 15 till 30.
Det kan man säkert göra med en någorlunda liknande team.
Men att sedan gå till 50 eller 100, helt plötsligt blir det ju en helt annan apparat.
Är ni alla sugna på det eller är det några som sitter och bara men fan det här är rätt kul att få göra sin grej och inte behöva tänka så mycket på det där.
Alltså hade du pratat med teamet här så är det ingen som gör samma grej idag som de gjorde för ett och ett halvt år sedan.
Det är väl lite det som jag personligen gillar som ledare är att affärsutveckla, liksom hitta nya sätt att sälja produkterna på och affärsutveckla sortiment och liksom följa marknaden.
Det vet ju du att e-handelsbranschen ser inte ut idag som den gjorde för två år sedan eller ett år sedan eller ett halvår sedan.
Det händer ju så mycket saker hela tiden, det händer snabbt.
Men där är det också viktigt att man har ett team som tar ansvar för sitt självlärande.
Precis som du säger, man har jobbat på ett visst sätt i några år eller ett år.
Då är det väldigt viktigt att man har ett team som är snabba och tar ansvar för sin arbetsroll och är självlärande inom det.
Hur kan jag applicera nya system eller AI i det jag jobbar med?
Vi tittar hela tiden på hur vi kan effektivisera.
Vi är sex personer.
Hur kan vi effektivisera varje roll?
Hur kan vi effektivisera kundresan?
Hur kan vi effektivisera logistiken, både in och ut?
Det brukar många fråga mig, men tycker ni fortfarande att det är kul efter 17 år?
Det är samma saker, fast det är verkligen inte samma sak.
För det händer så mycket saker.
Jag som kommer från en historia där jag har jobbat med affärsutveckling, ser det här som det här är det bästa man kan göra, för det är ju vi som driver besluten.
Vill vi göra det här, då gör vi det.
Ser vi en öppning här, vi testar.
Så det är fortfarande superkul.
Och ett jättebra tid där alla är verkligen med på resan.
Hur tänker du som ledare eller chef eller vd i detta, att din roll, har du gått in i tankesättet kring, det här behöver vi göra när vi dubblar en gång till, eller det här behöver jag lära mig, eller vad kommer min roll bli?
Sitter du någonsin och filosoferar kring sådana grejer?
Det som är utmaningen och det är ju att man har varit inne i bolaget så länge, så jag kan ju till 90 procent alla delar.
Det är väl det som är med utmaningen att våga släppa det operativa, och kanske kliva upp lite mer helikopterperspektiv och få det strategiska tänket.
Det är ju ett styrelsearbete och jobbet framåt att sätta den här planen.
Den är exa antal år och varje år ska de här sakerna infinna sig.
Det är allt ifrån att om det är 2025, nu ska vi byta er ens plattform.
Då är det bara att gå på det projektet.
Det är en add-on till allting annat som händer.
Nästa år är det här som ska göras och det som ska göras.
Det gäller att följa de planerna och se till att det finns resurser och medel till att kunna följa de planerna för att nå målet.
Hur nervös är du inför att byta e-handelsplattform?
Jag är inte så nervös.
Jag har gjort det förr och jag vet vad vi skulle tänka på där.
Nu när det finns mycket bra grejer på marknaden så ser jag att det här kommer gå jättebra.
Du har jobbat så länge här så det kanske är svårt att minnas, men du hade ju en tid innan barnkläder och Gegga-Moja och då jobbade du inte alls med detta.
Det var inte så att du jobbade med barnmoder på den tiden.
Nej gud, nej det här var ju verkligen någonting som jag fick upp ögonen för när jag var gravid med min första son som är idag, eller år fylla 18.
Nej men precis, då jobbade jag i musikbranschen på Sony Music.
Så hoppningen där är ju typ noll.
Men det är faktiskt inte det.
Min roll på Sony var, dels hade jag varit internationell pressansvarig ett tag, men sen gick jag över till att skapa ett eget affärsområde.
Här kommer väl lite den här intrapreneuren Sara in.
Att jag såg att okej, på den tiden, CD-skivsförsäljningen gick ner, den läskiga MP3-filen kom.
Det var mellan år mellan Spotify och vad ska våra artister tjäna pengar på?
Då såg jag en möjlighet att jobba med som brand manager, att det hjälpte artister att hitta varumärken som de kan jobba med.
Och affärsutvecklade det.
Där fanns det fortfarande ett affärsutvecklingstänk.
Det jag kan tycka att det är det vi gör på Gigamoja också, vi utvecklar vår affär hela tiden, hitta nya möjligheter, nya distributionskanaler.
Det är ändå att toucha lite på varandra.
Det är ju jättestort med skillnad men ändå inte.
På något sätt i mindset i alla fall.
Jag förstår det.
Det är olika produkter, olika affärsmodeller, men det är ändå att driva business på något sätt.
Ja precis.
Jag har alltid älskat sälj och affärsutveckling och affärer.
Sen om jag gör det med artister och musik eller jag gör det med barnkläder eller om jag hade gjort det med gymutrustning så tror jag att det liksom, jag hade haft samma fokus framåt på något sätt.
Vi sa det här innan, om någon lyssnar och vill höra mer om detta, så finns det ganska många intressanta händelser som du har varit med om.
Ni har haft en brand på kontoret, ni har haft översvämdning på lagret, ni har haft en del sjuka händelser under resans gång.
Jag tänker att du har berättat om några gånger, så får man gå och lyssna på andra.
Men det är ganska inspirerande historia i sig.
Men ni har också under de här senaste åren, som det har varit liksom lågkonjunktur, vuxit ganska mycket.
Men ni har också gjort en del minusresultat, det är inga stora mängder, men jag bara menar att det är ett minusresultat, till skillnad från vad ni kanske hade innan.
Och det är extremt mycket som har hänt de senaste fyra åren.
Upplever du själv att det här, är det här en stor händelse för bolaget, eller är detta bara business as usual?
Och hur har du hanterat de här åren?
Och hur gör man för att inte bli dum i huvudet under den tiden?
Ja, alltså precis som ni säger, det har hänt extremt mycket, men det har ju också gjort alla andra tidigare år, men att det kanske inte hänt lika stora grejer.
Men det är väl lite det här kaos-tänket man har fått som entreprenör, att liksom, vad ska hända nästa gång?
Det här var ju inte sist, när de ringde i somras och berättade att, oj, nu är det översvämning på lagret och pallarna flyter omkring, då har jag ändå man sett att det kommer lösa sig.
Så det är inte Jordens undergång liksom, utan det handlar bara om hur kommer det lösa sig.
Sen kanske man svär och gråter i någonting med, och sen så är det bara såhär, men på och åt igen.
Det handlar ju alltid om risk och konsekvenserna av alltihopa.
Du kan omöjligt vara så logisk i huvudet, ingen människa är så logisk i huvudet.
Du måste ha svurit en del när de ringde.
Jag kan säga att jag var mer nervös när vi haft survey-crusher.
När bolagets affärsystem har blivit attackerat och legat ned i tre veckor.
Då var jag mer nervös än vad jag var för översvämningen.
Branden var jobbigt, men där var det fortfarande business as usual.
I och med att det inte var lagret som brand.
Våra kunder märkte ju ingenting mer än att okej, x antal palla eller det blir försenningar.
Men nej, jag vet inte.
Jag vet ju att det här är inte sista gången.
Vi kommer att hända massa grejer.
Det kommer ju liksom, vi har varit med om så, det här är ju bara små grejer, det här är ju stora grejer, men vi har varit med om så mycket konstiga saker.
Är det surveycrashen som har varit det jobbigaste?
Eller finns det några i uppstarten som bara var ännu jobbigare för att det var så stort då?
Ja, det är allt ifrån att saker sitter fast i SOS-kanalen till surveycrashet till översvämningar till brand till personer, men det har varit mycket.
Men det är klart att Cyket har fått jobba lite och man har ju ganska mycket katastroftankar i huvudet och det har man också fått jobba med att få bort katastroftankarna.
Men jag tror snarare med att man är på sin helspänn för att man vet att det kommer ju att hända någonting, så är det.
Tänker du att nu har du fått några bajsmackor här så att nu borde du vara förskonad två år eller tänker du mer att ja, det här är standard nu så det här kommer att vara standard nu.
Jag bara är intresserad av hyring.
Nej, jag hoppas att jag inte får några mer bajsmackor faktiskt.
Jag hoppas att 2025 har börjat ganska glatt och jag hoppas att gaskyran kan få andas ut 2025 faktiskt.
Jag vill liksom inte ha någon jävla virus eller, ja, vi brukar skatta av det här på kontoret att nästa grej är någon sån där zombieinvention eller hela mördersnyglarattack, jag vet inte.
Ja, som heter det här, haha, albambu.
Ja, exakt.
Vi hoppas att det blir lite lugn och ro, men jag måste ändå säga att jag tycker att jag saknar ändå åren innan covid, där liksom, det var liksom, det var inte så jättemycket som stora grejer som hände, men nu efter det så vart det liksom, covid, brand, krig, lågkonjunktur, översvämning.
Alltså det har varit ganska, liksom, såklart mentalt tuffa år, men det skapar ju också lite jävla bränsle på skiten på något sätt.
Alltså, man blir ju lite mer, asså, nej jävlar, nu, det här ska inte döda oss liksom.
Ja men jag känner det.
Tävlingsmänniskan i oss som kommer fram här, helt enkelt.
Hur, hur, hur gör man för att nå, asså, det finns ju rätt mycket kläder i världen.
Och hur gör man för att nå ut med ett sånt här varumärke, speciellt återigen för att ni ligger inom en viss kvalitetsstandard, så då kanske man inte kan bara gifta mössor till 8000 influenser, och hoppas att de gör ett bra jobb, utan ni behöver ändå ha en tanke kring hur har ni jobbat för att synas eller att bygga varumärket den vägen?
Men vi har fantastiska ambassadörer som gillar varumärket och som vi tycker att vi går i linje med.
Man ska veta att 90% av allt material som vi har på sajt är användargenererat content.
Så att vi tycker att det är väldigt viktigt också att vara nära målgruppen, det ska vara en spridning av ålder, av etnicitet, vi måste hitta mixen där målgruppen är.
Då har vi hittat en fantastiskt fin ambassadörsgrupp som vi jobbar mycket med.
Men det här är ju någonting som vi vill jobba mer med.
För att nå ut och nå den unga mamman så skulle vi behöva lägga ännu mer krut på just influencermarketing och social media urlag.
Där vi kanske borde jobba mer med långsiktigare samarbeten.
Det tittar vi på hela tiden.
Vi tittar mycket på affiliates inom influencers också.
Hur gör ni när ni, för nu har ni väl gått utomlands en del.
Hur är det att gå utomlands med ett så etablerat varumärke som dessutom har ett namn som är så, för Giga Moja är ju typ världens bästa namn.
Men Giga Moja på engelska eller tyska är inte samma sak.
Här är det ju ofta så att man känner igen någon som har haft den, eller man har sett produkten genom åren på något sätt.
Det har ju byggts en grund på det sättet.
Hur gör ni när ni går utomlands?
Här handlar det ju om mycket att berätta storyn, hela entreprenörsresan men också vad varumärket står för och vad varumärket betyder på svenska.
Men när du säger berätta story, menar du er story då?
Ja men mina och Annas story, det är inliga entreprenörerna som också har varit småbarnsföräldrar en gång i tiden, och ser på behov och bygga förtroende där.
Men vi vet ju också, vi jobbar mycket med att våra kläder får tala för vad kunderna vill ha.
Vi trycker mycket på hållbarhet, kvaliteter och den delen.
Men precis som du säger när man går till nya marknader så har vi ju olika strategier för olika marknader, utifrån olika förutsättningar helt enkelt.
Nu är det väl liksom, nu i handen säljer vi till sex olika marknader.
Vi säljer egentligen hela världen, men det är sex marknader som vi har översatt, anpassat betal lösningar, frakt och logistik och allting sånt.
Det i kombination med att vi till exempel i Finland, Danmark och Tyskland säljer på Zalando, där vi liksom har hittat den vägen att erbjuda varumärket och göra marknadsföring i de kanalerna.
Sedan handlar det ju om att marknadsföra sig, hitta en bra kundresa för varje marknad, utifrån de nivåerna där vi säljer på marknaden.
Men sedan är det ju mycket trial and error, man får testa sig fram.
Det är det som är så fint med den digitala världen, att man ser ganska snabbt vad som funkar, och hur mycket krut man ska lägga i korgen.
Men vilken är den bästa andra marknaden utöver Sverige?
Nu är det ju Tyskland som kommer i kombination med Zalando.
Vi lanserade Zalando Tyskland här för några månader sedan, och har haft jättefin utveckling.
Det har gått lite, framförallt nu i mars har det gått superbra.
Så det är jättekul.
Vi har också en marknad som är lite oväntad, som är på tredje plats, vilket är Tjeckien.
Ja, det var inte det jag tänkte chansa på.
Nej, exakt, det tänker man inte på.
Där vi har en annan typ av strategi, där vi egentligen har en stor återförsäljare med ett viss sortiment, men vi ser ju att vi på vår egen e-com får in mycket kunder nu från Tjeckien.
Är det samma produkter som säljs på andra marknader som Sverige?
Är det samma köpmönster?
Nej, vi har inte anpassat sortimentet till specifika marknader, det har vi inte gjort.
Men ser ni att om vi säljer 15 procent sådana mössor i Sverige, så säljer ni ungefär samma i Tjeckien och Tyskland?
Ja, man kan se att det är lite 80-20 där, att det är alltid 20 procent av artiklarna.
Det är det som funkar och det är inte så jättestor skillnad mellan marknaderna.
Vi kan se till exempel i och för sig att finnarna går igång på gula barnkläder.
Det är sådana där detaljer vi kan nörda ner oss i.
Och sen som i karaktärerna kan vi också se att vissa karaktärer är större på vissa marknader än andra, utifrån.
Jag tänkte när du tog upp det här med grundaresan, så tycker jag ändå att det måste vi få in i podden också.
När ni drog igång detta så var det era mamma som satt och gjorde barnkläder.
Det var inte bara första kvarten liksom, utan det blev höll på ett litet tag.
Anna, min syster, startade ju Gegemo, hon kom från reklambranschen, hon startade Gegemo, jag kan göra fel på åtal igen, men jag tror att det var 2005, då egentligen var det en second hand butik.
Men som du sa, mamma är sömmerska och Anna har ju som alltid haft idéer och velat utveckla saker och skapa saker.
Och då fick mamma sy det Anna ville ha.
På den tiden fanns det inga svarta barnkläder.
Allt hade en liten söt nalle på sig som Anna inte ville ha.
Det fanns inga svarta vinteroråler.
Men det var så där, så mamma fick sy.
Och sen när vi beslutades för att driva bolaget själva, när Anna fick sitt andra och jag fick mitt första barn och sa så här, nu startar vi ett bolag och så får vi se om det här håller i ett och ett halvt år som jag ska vara mammaledig.
Då sydde mamma första kollektionen.
Hon har sålt, sytt över tusen plagg liksom.
Så hon har varit en jättestor del med på resan i början där.
Vi började i hennes källare och hon hade kläder i hela fastigheten typ.
Men det var ju, ja.
Så att, det var år.
Sen, apropå tarisker, sen åkte vi ner på en barnmässa i Köpenhamn, hade med oss en provkollektion som mamma hade sytt, beträffade en producent och visade till honom såhär, tittade på varandra och bara, är ni förbärd eller bristad?
Här, ta det här, här är ordrarna, hoppas att det kommer att gå bra.
Och så gick det bra.
Var det för att din mamma inte orkade mer eller var det bara för stor?
Det blev för stora volymer, det blev liksom, det gick inte att hantera längre liksom.
Jag bara älskar att det skulle finnas en liten såhär, Cido-produktline, som är din mammas produktline.
Du vet, en produkt som är made by, jag vet inte vad den heter men...
Agneta heter den.
Agnetas finest, ja.
Jag vet inte vad hon skulle säga bara idag.
Om hon skulle säga alla ni.
Ja, jag älskar, jag är ju lite sucker för, men du vet, allt som är gammalt, allt som är såhär, allt som har ett heritage eller vad man ska säga.
Jag tycker bara att det är charmigt att det finns en...
Ja, och vi får fortfarande den frågan, fortfarande.
Har ni produktion själva?
Sier ni själva?
Nej, några år sedan det hände.
Att vi slutade med det.
Men det var många år som liksom, och hon hoppar in ibland också nu när det är felsiddagrejer eller Anna behöver ha liksom påvisare, någon funktion i någonting och så där så kan hon hjälpa till.
Absolut.
Vad är det man söker?
Hur länge har ni, du sa att ni var sex kolleger.
Har ni liksom hängt ihop här de senaste åren eller har det ökat på på slutet?
Nej men det har ökat på och alla har ju som du förstår som det här klassiska uttrycket, har många hattar på sig.
Men vi har liksom hittat en bra form med en bra arbetsbelastning för alla olika delarna och alla ansvarare för sina saker och stå till svars för sitt ansvar som de har.
Så vi har hittat ett ganska bra, ett bra tid.
Sen så kan man ju se att vissa delar så skulle man ju behöva utveckla och ta in mer folk på, alltså framåt för att kunna göra resan nu framåt.
Det är inom marknad, det kan vara inom ekonomi och så där.
Men annars så, från start har vi jobbat med att effektivisera så mycket som möjligt.
Så det är mycket som är liksom, liksom, ja, med kopplingar och ja du vet ju vad det innebär.
Hur tror du det är att komma in i ett bolag som har den bakfrunden som ni har.
Det är två systrar som driver det, ni är på plats och snackar ni någonsin om det eller bara förutsätter ni att folk hittar sin roll i det där?
Jag bara tänker att jag hade tyckt det var lite knepigt att komma in om jag hade vågat liksom, fan ja, ska vi verkligen ha glassar på det här?
Ja, nej men absolut.
Men där tror jag att det, alltså det finns ju två aspekter.
Det går ju jäkligt fort här, så.
Och det som gällde på måndag kanske inte gäller riktigt på fredagen.
Så att den inställningen måste man ha.
Och sen så tror jag precis som du säger att man måste vara lite tuff för att ifrågasätta mig och Anna ibland, så här, hallå, hur har ni tänkt här?
Eller, det här tycker inte jag är någon bra idé, liksom.
Och det, alltså, där vill jag säga med självinsikt att vi är ganska sköna där tror jag.
Alltså snarare tvärtom.
Men det fanns anledningar till att vi ville ta in mer delägare bara för att vi ville bli lite utmanade och ifrågasatta.
Det är ingenting som säger att vi vet exakt hur resan framåt ska vara, liksom.
Så att, och det blir vi, liksom.
Har du reflekterat, du ser att ni är ganska sköna där.
Vad har du för stora svagheter som sker?
Nej men jag har väl liksom, just svagheterna att jag har ju så jäkla, alltså jag har ju koll på alla flöden, all, liksom all it-struktur, allting.
Jag vet vad man kan göra med befintlig liksom setup.
Och det är klart att ibland så kan det bli såhär micromanagement, men jag försöker att gå in och liksom säga att såhär fungerar det och så försöker jag släppa.
Du får återkomma om det inte liksom funkar framåt.
Så att det är väl egentligen det.
Och det är väl det som är vår största utmaning nu i den storleken som vi är.
Att det går liksom inte bara att ha någon som sitter och jobbar med det strategiska och planerna framåt, utan jag måste vara operativ i verksamheten liksom.
Men jag jobbar med det och det går framåt.
Så det är ju bra.
Ja, absolut, höra.
Och hur går det?
Jag ska bara sluta fråga också lite.
Du har säkert fått frågan vid flera tillfällen och nu får du upplepa det en gång till, men det här med att jobba med sitt syskon, liksom som man säkert träffar några andra gånger också.
Ni har ju, det blir ju så med syskon att man har ju en koppling på något sätt som gör att det är okej att man inte håller med varandra, för att man är ändå vän eller man är liksom familj i slutändan.
Och det gör ju att er dialog kanske kan vara lite mer öppen än vad de andra kollegerna kan vara, för de har ju inte samma grundarkoppling.
Nej, precis.
Hur är det att jobba med sin syster, liksom att äga bolaget med sin syster?
Alltså vi har liksom aldrig, helt galet när man säger det, vi har liksom aldrig under de här 17 åren varit oönse vad vi ska eller vad vi ska satsa på eller liksom vägen framåt eller så där.
Sen så tror jag att...
Hade hon sagt samma sak?
Ja men jag vill inte tro det faktiskt.
Vi har aldrig liksom haft ett kaffel, ett bråk om Gägge Moja.
Okej.
Vi har aldrig liksom varit, och då har vi varit liksom i bra tider och dåliga tider.
Det är klart att det har varit situationer där jag har varit skitnervöst när det liksom var, ska vi klara av det här nu då liksom?
Man sover lite dåligt några nätter och så där, men då har vi funnit att vi kan stötta varandra.
Sen så tror jag också att, både jag och Anna som personer är personer som inte är långsiktiga.
Långsinta kanske.
Vad sa du?
Långsiktiga verkar ni vara.
Långsinta, exakt.
Helt rätt tack.
Tycker man nåt så säger man nåt och så är det över med det.
Till vardags så har vi nog en ganska respekterad relation så, tycker jag.
Det måste vi ändå säga.
Jag vet ju andra, syskon, att vi är ett bolag och det blir på annat sätt, men vi är också så olika.
Vi respekterar varandras olikenheter.
Det är som jag brukar säga, Anna gillar att köpa och jag gillar att sälja.
Men vi gör ju jättemycket ihop i att driva bolaget framåt.
Jag är glad att vi är två, om jag säger så.
Jag älskar det.
Sara, stort tack för att du var med och stort tack för varumärket som du har byggt upp.
Det är fascinerande.
Jag älskar när man har byggt ett varumärket som är någonting.
Väldigt många pratar om att man ska jobba med varumärket.
Vi ska bygga upp en bild.
Absolut, det är en bild.
Det är ingenting än.
Men här har du faktiskt byggt ett varumärket som är någonting.
Det är väldigt imponerande.
Det är Joanna jättestolt över.
Vi är så taggade för vad som kommer skall faktiskt.
Gegemoja är ju typ världens bästa namn.
Men Gegemoja på...
Gegemoja, Gegemoja, Gegemoja, Gegemoja...